[Music]
like I have a target on my back and
because of that I should make smart
decisions and recently I didn't Kevin
Hart is owning up to his mistakes on
Saturday he issued an apology to his
wife Anika Parrish and two kids
Hendricks and heaven on social media I
made a bad error in judgment and put
myself in an environment where only bad
things can happen and they did and in
doing that I know that I'm gonna hurt
the people closest to me who I've talked
to and apologized to be my wife and my
kids and I just you know it's a moment
it's a moment where you will you know
you're wrong and there's no excuses for
your wrong behavior at the end of the
day man I just simply gotta do better a
rep for Kevin shared in a statement to
ET quote someone tried to set kevin up
in a failed extortion attempt as law
enforcement is involved we cannot
comment further i'm not gonna also allow
a person to to have financial gain off
of my mistakes after Kevin spoke out in
the new Instagram post a source close to
the 38 year old star tells ET his main
priority is his family quote he's okay
he needs to keep his family together my
wife makes me smile so I have no room to
complain my kids adore back in July the
comedian laughed off cheating
allegations after footage surfaced of
him with a woman outside of his Miami
Beach hotel
[Music]
at the time Kevin denied claims that he
was unfaithful to his pregnant wife
telling et it's absolutely not true I'm
a good husband I'm just there
[Music]